Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Wir wollen auf die spanische La Liga blicken und uns mal angucken, was da so los ist im Lande von Real Madrid, Barcelona und all den anderen wunderbaren Vereinen mit Till Oppermann und Sascha Felter von Cabanis Friseur. Servus Sascha, servus Till. Schön, dass ihr beide hier mit dabei seid. Wir haben heute ausnahmsweise mal zwei Gäste. Wir wollen das ausprobieren. Ihr habt euch beide bei mir angeboten. Und weil ich weiß, dass ihr bei Cabanis Friseur, was ja vielleicht dem einen oder anderen Hörer und der einen oder anderen Hörerin noch vertraut ist, wir hatten mal über die Welttalente des Weltfußballs gesprochen. Ein doppeltes Welt, das sei hier gestattet. Weil ihr euch da so sehr auch mit internationalen Ligen beschäftigt, war das jetzt mal an der Zeit, dass wir mit euch auch in einem Kurzpass darüber sprechen. Und ich habe vernommen, vor dieser Ausgabe, es fehlt noch auf der Pod-Roll, aber Sascha, ihr habt jetzt einen eigenen Podcast.
Genau, also seit Kurzem haben wir einen eigenen Podcast, wo wir in relativ unregelmäßigen Abständen über den Weltfußball sprechen, über irgendwelche Spiele sprechen oder wonach uns halt gerade so ist.
Das war ein flammendes Play-Doyer, sich Cavani-Spiele anzuhören. Aber wir sind ein bisschen ermattet, das ist jetzt schon Versuch Nummer 4, glaube ich, eine Aufnahme. Aber diesmal läuft die Aufnahme und alles funktioniert und alle hören sich gegenseitig. So soll das sein. Und dann können wir jetzt nämlich auch sprechen über den Stand in der spanischen Liga. Und von außen betrachtet, Till, sieht das eigentlich so aus, als hätte sich da gar nichts getan. Auf den ersten drei Plätzen Real, Barca, Atletico. Ich glaube aber, wenn man im Detail hinguckt, dann war es jetzt doch schon ein anderer Saisonbeginn als in vergangenen Spielzeiten. Wenn wir mal mit Real anfangen, wie würdest du denn deren Saisonstart beschreiben?
Prinzipiell kann man den Saisonstart von Real als relativ gut beschreiben. Was man angesichts der 0-3-Liederlage bei PSG in der Champions League vielleicht gar nicht so denken würde, ist Real aber in Spanien in der Liga die einzige ungeschlagene Mannschaft. Hat fünfmal gewonnen, dreimal unentschieden gespielt, dabei teilweise nur teilweise überzeugt und hat auch noch einige Probleme. Zum Beispiel Eden Hazard, der im letzten Spiel sein erstes Tor erzielen konnte, nachdem er im Sommer von Schleswig verpflichtet wurde für eine horrende Ablösung von 100 Millionen mit Übergewicht ankam und sehr schwer ins Rollen kam, jetzt endlich getroffen hat. Ja, das könnt ihr euch aussuchen.
Also die Ergebnisse stimmen, bis auf die Champions League, also bei PSG 0-3 verloren, zu Hause gegen ein dezimiertes Brücke zurückgelegen und dann gerade noch irgendwie das 2 zu 2 geholt. Und du hast jetzt an Eden Hazard aufgehängt. Hat sich denn taktisch bei Real irgendwas verändert? Ist das jetzt so, wie wir sie untersehen, den sie dann schon mal gesehen haben, oder wie würde es das beschreiben?
Ja, gut, da kann man einhaken. Taktisch hat sich bei Real relativ wenig verändert. Das kann man an einer Statistik festmachen, dass nämlich Toni Kroos und Casemiro, die ja schon in den Zidane-Jahren immer gesetzt waren, bis jetzt Kroos kurz vor Schluss gegen Granada runter muss, 99 respektive 96 Prozent aller Pflichtspielminuten auf dem Platz standen. Also Zidane setzt ein bisschen auf das alte Gerüst und fährt damit bis jetzt auch ganz gut. Was aber dem Umbruch, der den Real schon nötig hat, was man ja auch im letzten Jahr ein bisschen gesehen hat, leider etwas in den Weg steht, bislang aber erfolgreich. Unter anderem auch, weil Benzema in sieben Spielen sechs Mal getroffen hat und sich immer mehr seit dem Abgang von Ronaldo als die Nummer-1-Option in der Realoffensive hervortut.
Sascha, wie ist denn so deine Meinung zu Madrid? Wie viel Fisch und wie viel Fleisch ist denn das jetzt gewesen nach diesen acht Spielen in der Liga und eben den zwei angesprochenen in der Champions League?
Naja, also ich muss sagen, ich war ziemlich überrascht, dass Real jetzt immer noch unbesiegt ist in der Liga, weil irgendwie ging so diese allgemeine Erwartungshaltung von mir und auch anderen Real-Fans so auseinander, dass Real eben nicht so diese unantastbare Mannschaft ist, wie es vielleicht so die Tabelle suggeriert hat. Also man hat jetzt einen ziemlich durchwachsenen Saisonstart gehabt, mit Unentschieden gegen Valladolid, Villarreal und dann noch so einem Zittersieg gegen Levanza. Nicht zu vergessen, dem 4 zu 2 jetzt gegen Granada, wo man lange gut gespielt hat, 3-0 Führung gegangen ist, Hazard, Endi ist ja ein erstes Tor gemacht hat und dann völlig unnötig die Führung fast hergeschenkt hätte. Ariola hat hinten den Ball zu lange gehalten, da gab es noch ein paar Meter, hat irgendwelche Faxen da hinten in sein Tor gemacht und ist dann im Strafraum, das war dann irgendwie auch nicht so richtig souverän, also es wirkt zu als Material. An sich immer noch das alte Realsein von Zidane's erster Ära, aber da würde ich da anfälliger sein. Nach diesen zwei Toren darf man einfach als Real nicht sich von Granada so gut sie auch sind, auf die kann man nachher denke ich nochmal zu sprechen, da fand sich der nicht irgendwie die Prädogie bringen lassen nach einer 3-0-Führung. Er hatte natürlich noch Glück, dass James dann noch das 4-2 gemacht hat, hat dann noch sein Trikot ausgezogen, wurde von den Madridistas gefeiert, also scheint es auch wieder eine Versöhnung gegeben zu haben zwischen Spieler, Verein und auch Zidane.
Und wie würde der das jetzt bewerten eben vor dem Hintergrund, dass Real so viel investiert hat? Also ein Transfer-Saldo von mal eben schlanken, 177, 5 Millionen Euro minus. Ich nehme alle Daten von Transfermarkt.de an der Stelle und ihr habt ja Eden Hazard schon genannt. Dazu hat man ja aber zum Beispiel auch einen Lukas Jovic geholt für 60 Millionen, ein Eder Militao von Porto für 50 Millionen, ein Ferland Mendy von Olympique Lyon für 48 Millionen, ein Rodrigo, linksaußen Spieler von Santos aus Brasilien, für 45 Millionen. Also ja voll reingelangt und wenn wir jetzt mal zum Beispiel mit Jovic anfangen, Till, wie haben denn dann so jetzt mal an ihm nachexerziert, die Transfers bisher eingeschlagen? Hazard habt ihr ja schon kurz thematisiert.
Also an ihm kann man eigentlich real gut exerzieren. Jovic hat bis jetzt noch kein Tor gemacht, zugegeben auch nur Kurzentsätze bekommen, aber ist mit nun 214 Minuten, glaube ich, torlos einer der schwächsten Reallstürmer der letzten Jahre. Da hat die Marke sogar eine relativ ästliche Statistik geführt. Und der Jovic jedes Spiel mit jeder Minute weiter nach oben steigt. Als unproduktivster Realeinkauf seit Langem wird er da verspottet. Nur Higuain, kann man am Rand sagen, der hat noch länger gebraucht. Der hat 600 Minuten für den ersten Realtor gebraucht und war ja dann später ein ganz brauchbarer Stürmer. Also muss man abwarten. Natürlich auch ein großer Sprung von Frankfurt zu Real. Doch anfangs ist er auf jeden Fall noch ein bisschen ein Stotterstaat, kann man sagen.
Ich meine, gut, diese Minutenzählerei ist natürlich auch mal ein bisschen ungerecht, aber zeigt so ein bisschen, da greift noch nicht so wirklich ein Rat ins andere. Und trotzdem reicht es ja für die Liga, Sascha. Was sagt denn das über La Liga und die Verfolger aus?
Ja gut, also man muss natürlich dazu sagen, dass die Verfolger, also vor allen Dingen Atletico, natürlich auch einen Umbruch hinter sich hat im Sommer. Barcelona hat aktuell noch ein bisschen mit der Form zu kämpfen aufgrund von von Messi's Abstinenz, Griezmann versucht, im Sturm einzubinden. Auch im Mittelfeld versucht man jetzt einen Umbruch hinzubekommen mit Artur, der aktuell in einer ganz guten Verfassung ist. Und Frenkie de Jong, der wohl die Zukunft von Basel sein wird und Busketz und Raketic gerade immer weiter hinter treffen. Da versucht man jetzt aktuell eben auch den Umbruch offen in Herzen. Aber ansonsten würde ich nicht unbedingt sagen, dass es jetzt per se an der Schwäche von La Liga liegt. Das würde ich jetzt nicht sagen. Es gibt genug gute Mannschaften, die Realta Paroli bieten können. Aber letztendlich ist es ja trotzdem immer noch eine Weltklasse bis jetzt, die die Realta hat. Und zweifel können sich dann immer noch James oder Benzema oder Azar mit einer sehr guten Einzelaktion durchsetzen. Also würde ich jetzt den Mannschaften dahinter keinen so großen Vorwurf machen.
Braucht ihr aber auch schon die Brücke, dass wir mal näher zum Beispiel auf Barca gucken? Du hast jetzt schon ein paar Stichpunkte genannt. Ich ergänze die noch, indem ich sage, Barca zwar auf Platz zwei mit 16 Punkten, zwei Punkte Rückstand auf Real, aber nach acht Spielen schon zwei Niederlagen in der Liga. Was passt dabei Barca noch nicht?
Wie gesagt, man hat eben noch die Probleme im Offensivspiel, dass da noch einige Automatismen nicht ganz so greifen wie in der letzten Saison noch.
Aber sie haben da schon 20 Tore erzielt. Also 20 Tore nach acht Spielen, das hört sich jetzt für mich ehrlich gesagt nicht nach Offensivproblemen an.
Ich meine, eher so die kollektiven Abläufe passen da immer noch nicht ganz so, wie man es vielleicht so kennt von Barca. Da hat man immer noch sehr auf die Einzelaktionen von Suárez gehofft, der gegen Sevilla ein wunderbares Fallrückzieher-Tor erzählt hat. Und auch Rolf Griesmann, der auch nicht ganz so richtig eingebunden ist bei Barca, weil er oftmals als linker Flügelspieler spielen musste, was nicht so ganz seine perfekte Position ist. In der Verteidigung hat man auch Probleme, weil Longley ungewohnte Sprechen zeigt dieses Jahr. Man hat dann eigentlich in manchen Spielen noch Glück gehabt, dass Tere Stegen aktuell in so einer richtig guten Verfassung ist.
Du hast keine Angst vor Uli Gönes, der hört das hier nicht. Du darfst ruhig sagen, dass Tere Stegen ein guter Torhüter ist. Aber das heißt, die Abwehr ist so ein bisschen das Problem mit zehn Gegentreffern nach acht Spieltagen. Und wenn ich mir die Spiele so angucke, Till, dann sehe ich da ja auch wirklich einige überraschende Ergebnisse. Unter anderem eben 0 zu 2 in Granada. Das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt das, was man erwartet. Barca bei einem Aufsteige und dann eine klare Niederlage, wo Barca ja auch gar nicht so viele Chancen hatte, wenn ich mich richtig an dieses Spiel erinnere.
Ja, genau. Und was man auch noch zu den Toren, will ich noch dazu hinzufügen, zu den vielen geschossenen Toren. 14 davon sind halt auch aus drei Spielen, resultieren aus drei Spielen, die in relativ offen geführt wurden, mit Betis, mit Valencia und mit Sevilla. Also Teams, die offensiv spielen wollen. Und damit sich Barca dann auch ein bisschen Räume geöffnet haben. Aber sobald Gegner ein bisschen defensiv durchmachen, wie das Granada in dem angesprochenen Spiel sehr gut gemacht hat, wird es halt schwierig. Also da kann man vielleicht auch gleich darauf eingehen, auf das Spiel von Granada. Da hatte Granada 26 Prozent Ballbesitz. Das doppelte an Fouls. Also da hat man einfach gesehen, wenn eine Mannschaft sich Barca einfach mit Kraft und auch mit Überzeugung ein bisschen entgegengestellt, kommen die in Probleme. Sobald die Räume eng werden, ist es noch nicht das, was man von Barca kennt. Und deswegen wurde der Verletzter schmerzlich erwischt, weil er vermisst, weil der kann ja genau so was auflösen mit seiner Kreativität.
Also nur einen Torschuss hatte Barca in diesem Spiel. Das heißt, selbst wenn eine Torschüsse reingegangen wären, dann wäre es ein 2 zu 1 geworden pro Granada. Insgesamt waren es neun Abschlüsse für Granada und acht für Barca. Ich weiß nicht, wann ich zuletzt so schlechte Statistiken gesehen habe. Na ja, vielleicht doch, nämlich im Spiel in Dortmund. Da konnte man ja auch Barca ganz gut beobachten als deutscher Fußballfan. Da fand ich, Sascha, hat man ja die Probleme, die ihr jetzt benennt, auch schon exemplarisch sehen können. Dass man hinten eigentlich nur das Degen es zu verdanken hatte, dass man da nicht verloren hat. Und vorne hatte da Barca ja auch kaum Abschlüsse. Da war es nämlich auch nur ein Torschuss.
Gegen Inter kann man vielleicht auch noch anfügen. Da war ja auch Inter, die deutlich bessere Mannschaft hat, früh geführt. Und dann mussten zwei Einzelaktionen her, um das Spiel noch umzuwiegen, was geklappt hat. Zum Glück für Barca aber jetzt auch nicht auf einen tollen Offensivplan zurückzuführen ist, wo die Abläufe stimmen und man halt auch von Anfang an quasi auf den Platz bringt, was man unter dem Namen Barcelona endlich versteht und erwartet.
Also irgendwie ist es ja logisch, dass eine Mannschaft abhängig ist vom vielleicht besten Stürmer der Welt oder definitiv einem der besten Stürmer der Welt. Wir wollen jetzt nicht die alte Messi-Ronaldo-Diskussion hier an der Stelle aufmachen. Das brauchen wir nicht. Aber es ist ein sehr, sehr guter Stürmer, dass der dann fehlt, wenn er nicht spielt. Das ist ja klar. Aber wenn ich mir ansonsten den Kader angucke, müsste ja eigentlich Sascha genügend Potential vorhanden sein. Und dann hat man ja auch noch so etwas wie den jungen Fati. Das haben vielleicht auch die einen oder anderen Hörer und Hörerinnen mitbekommen, der mit 16 Jahren debütiert hat und so ein bisschen wie die nächste große Entdeckung galt. Also gibt es denn arg viele Gründe, dass das bei Barca so stackend läuft außer Messi?
Wie gesagt, die Tatsache natürlich, dass einzelne Spieler, mal Messi ausgenommen, aktuell noch einige Vormkrisen haben wie Longley und natürlich hat er auch auf der links-zuteiligen Position aktuell drei verschiedene Spieler jetzt schon eingesetzt. Also Rorty Alba hat zwar am Anfang noch gespielt, war dann aber verletzt, kommt jetzt wieder. Dann hat Junior Firpo der Neuzugang von Real Betis hinten links gespielt, auf den Valverde wohl gar nicht so stark setzt und dann hat hinten links, glaube ich, auch noch mal Semedo gespielt. Also alleine schon, dass drei Spieler jetzt schon hinten links spielen mussten, zeigt ja schon, dass da auch schon viel umgestellt werden muss und dass da natürlich ein bisschen Zeit braucht, um die Automatismus einzustellen und einzustudieren, ist auch völlig klar. Valverde ist jetzt auch nicht so der Trainer, der jetzt dafür bekannt ist, bei Barca irgendwelche großen mannschaftstaktischen Umstellungen zu machen oder irgendwelche neuen Spielphilosophien umzusetzen, sondern vertraut eher darauf, dass das große Gesamtkonstrukt funktioniert. Das ist halt nicht wie bei Atletico zum Beispiel, die eben stark über das Kollektiv kommen, sondern eher versucht, so dass dieser Heldenfußball eher am Vordergrund steht.
Damit hast du ja das perfekte Stichwort schon liefert. Die goldene Brücke hast du gebaut und die ist von Barca zu Atletico ja auch sehr einfach und man kann sie auch einfach mit Antoine Griezmann benennen. Der ist ja von den einen zu den anderen gewechselt. Und wenn ich mir jetzt einfach nur mal die Bilanz von Atletico Madrid angucke, Till, dann sehe ich vier Siege, drei Unentschieden, eine Niederlage, 15 Punkte. Damit ist man nur einen Punkt hinter Barca und drei Punkte hinter gegen Real Madrid. Aber man hat das Atletico-Madridigste-Tor-Verhältnis, das man haben kann. Nach acht Spieltagen 7 zu 4 erzielte Tore und daraus dann 15 Punkte erzielt. Gehe ich dann recht in meine Ferndiagnose, obwohl man sich ja einen sehr talentierten Stürmer als Ersatz für Chris Mann geholt hat, dass da noch nicht so alles rund läuft in der Offensive?
In der Analyse gehst du sehr recht. Bei Atletico muss man von vorne weg sagen, dass im Sommer ein großer Umbruch stattgefunden hat. Man hat in jedem Mannschaftsteil wichtige Spieler verloren. Gaudín, der ihr seid, ewig kalten hinten quasi das Rückgrat gebildet hat, ist gegangen. Philippe Luis ist jetzt auch weg, musste ersetzt werden. Davor Rodrié im Mittelfeld ist zu Manchester City gewechselt, der letztes Jahr so ein bisschen Dreh- und Angelpunkt war und die Fäden gezogen hat. Und dann stürmt natürlich Chris Mann, der ein bisschen vergleichbar ist, wie Barcelona eigentlich, auch wenn Atletico ganz anders spielt, in jedem Angriff irgendwie den Ball am Fuß hatte, ob er jetzt abgeschlossen hat, ob er den eingeleitet hat, je nachdem. Die alle musstest du ersetzen. Defensiv gelingt es bisher ganz gut. Da hast du einen typisch Simeone sehr starken Defensivverbund gebaut. Links Renan Lodi, ein Brasilianer, der neu ist, hat sich schon ganz gut eingefügt. Genauso wie in der Mitte, wo du relativ gleichwertige Innenverteidiger hast, wie zum Beispiel Philippe von Porto neu gekommen ist, zu den schon vorhandenen guten Spielern wie Jemines, der jetzt so in die Rolle reinwächst, die Godin hatte und Savic. Defensiv funktioniert es schon sehr gut. Offensiv ist das Problem. Da komme ich auf Feliz, den du angesprochen hast. Der ist eben 19 Jahre alt, zum ersten Mal im fremden Land. Er braucht doch einfach noch Zeit. Simeone hat letztens auch gesagt, Griezmann hat erst mit 26 so richtig bei Atletico seinen Durchbruch gehabt. Also hat Feliz schon noch 7 Jahre. Er verdeutlicht auch, dass er ihm Zeit geben möchte. Das ist die andere Frage. Genau deshalb, weil Diego Simeone weiß, dass er keine 7 Jahre hat, hat er auch schon andere Spieler wie Vitolo und Correa so ein bisschen in die Pflicht genommen letztes Mal im Interview. Also es knirrt schon so ein bisschen. Der ist auch ein bisschen sauer, dass offensiv nichts funktioniert. Vor allem, weil Feliz eigentlich der einzige Lichtblick war mit einigen ganz guten Aktionen. Und die haben jetzt in der Länderspielpause auf jeden Fall ohne die ganzen Spieler einige Arbeit gehabt und sich überlegen müssen, was sie jetzt machen. Also auch Costa & Morata zum Beispiel im Sturm. Große Namen, die bis jetzt einfach kaum Torgefahr ausstrahlen.
Wobei ich jetzt eigentlich nur einen Witz machen wollte, aber Sascha, ist denn Diego Semeone wirklich umstritten in Atletico?
Nein, das wollte ich damit nicht sagen.
Also ich denke nicht, dass Hilda sagen wollte. Also ich glaube nicht, dass Semeone jetzt irgendwie in Frage gestellt wird. Denke ich mal, Heldestatus in Atletico. Aber ich habe irgendwie schon das Gefühl, also gefühlt ist es so, dass bei Atletico der Umbruch schon seit zwei Jahren hätte stattfinden müssen. Also sowohl spielerisch als auch irgendwie von der ganzen Mentalität. Also man hat es seit dem Titel damals, 2014, das stimmt, 2013, hat man es eben nicht geschafft.
14.
Ja, 14, genau. Und da hat man es auch noch in Europa liegen noch, ganz gut Leistung gemacht, aber irgendwie ist so diese Gewinnermentalität weg. Ja, das stimmt. Aber trotzdem so diese Gewinnermentalität, finde ich, ist da schon ein bisschen abhandengekommen seitdem. Seitdem auch Kortoavec ist, Gaby ist damals auch, glaube ich, mitgegangen zu der Zeit. Und ja, aber ich glaube nicht, dass da Simione uns jetzt dann irgendwie ab Winter oder so mit Champagnerfußball begeistert hat, sondern er sagt halt auch immer, dass er sagt halt selber auch immer, dass sie halt, ich spiele ein Liebste erst mal hinten zu Null, da kann er erst mal schon nicht verlieren. Das ist für ihn natürlich das Hauptargument. Wenn er nicht spielt, kann er sich verlieren und alles andere, da haben sie halt immer die Qualität oder die Möglichkeit, Tore zu erzielen. Und dann nimmt er lieber so ein Null-Null mit. Die haben jetzt die letzten drei Spiele Null-Null gespielt, glaube ich, wenn ich es richtig gelesen habe.
Genau, die letzten drei Liga-Spiele, alle Null-Null.
Und wie geht das mit den gerade erst sieben geschossenen Toren? Letzte Saison war es zum selben Zeitpunkt, haben sie neun Tore geschossen. Also würde ich nicht sagen, dass es eine so große Krise ist. Sie haben halt nur in den entscheidenden Spielen dann nicht das 1-0 gemacht. Und das ist halt bei Atletico manchmal das Problem. Wenn sie so bis 70. Minute das Tor nicht machen, dann werden sie auch manchmal ungeduldig.
Ja, und Atletico ist ein großer Vorteil in diesem Jahr. Es ist halt auch, dass Barcelona und Real beide nicht souverän sind bisher und deswegen einfach nicht davon ziehen, während man selber noch Probleme hat. Und solange die Abwehr nicht schlechter wird, wird Atletico im Laufe der Saison auch noch mehr Spiele gewinnen. Denn mit der Qualität, die du ja trotzdem irgendwie auch namensechnisch hast und individuell wirst du auch nach und nach wieder einen Offensivverbund finden, der funktioniert.
Ja gut, das ist das klar. Ich habe auch einen Sieg noch unterschlagen. Also drei der letzten vier Spiele waren 0 zu 0 Spiele in der Liga. Auf Mallorca, dem aktuell Tabellen, 18. da konnte man ja 2 zu 0 in Unterzahl sogar gewinnen. Und in der Champions League steht man ja auch ganz gut da mit einem 2 zu 2 gegen Juve zu Hause und dann in Moskau bei Lokomotive gewonnen mit 2 zu 0. Also irgendwie Atletico, komplett andere Namen auf dem Spielfeld. Hernandez fehlt ja zum Beispiel auch, das vergisst man ja fast schon ein bisschen, weil wir uns da schon so an diesen Wechsel gewöhnen konnten schon seit so vielen Monaten. Aber ansonsten hat sich eigentlich nicht so viel verändert, außer dass ich das eine oder andere noch finden muss. Das würde ich jetzt so ein bisschen als Fazit aus diesem Segment mitnehmen. Oder liege ich da falsch?
Nee, da liest du richtig, das würde ich genauso unterschreiben.
Dann wollen wir dem auch nichts hinzufügen, sondern über eine Mannschaft sprechen, die ich nicht da oben erwartet hätte in der Region Tabellenplatz 4. Und das ist Granada. Was zur Hölle, Sascha, ist denn bei Granada los? Ist das jetzt ein Strohfeuer, diese 14 Punkte mit vier Siegen, zwei Unentschieden und zwei Niederlagen nach acht Spieltagen?
Also ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass es aus komplett heiterem Himmel kommt. Also Granada, muss man sagen, ist schon eine gute Mannschaft, die von der Spielanlage her viele Sachen schon gut macht. Sie spielen halt aus einem 4-2-3-1 heraus relativ einfachen Fußball. Sie versuchen da über dieses so ein bisschen Nagelsmann-ähnliches steil-klatsch-steil-Fußball auf die Flügel zu kommen und von dort aus den Strafe gut zu übersetzen. Das können sie halt wirklich ganz gut. Aber mehr halt auch nicht. Das ist wirklich der einzige Plan, den sie eben haben. Sie haben ja keinen Plan B, aber den Plan A setzen sie halt sehr gut um. Sie haben dann zu noch einige ganz gute und ausgepuffte Fußballer, vor allen Dingen auch Roberto Soldado, der schon ein ganz guter Stürmer ist, der auch sich für lange Bälle immer anbietet. Also falls dieses Kurzpass-Spiel nicht funktioniert, dann können sie eben noch diesen langen Ball auf Soldado spielen. Sie haben dann im Mittelfeld und in anderen Mannschaften zählen eigentlich jetzt nicht unbedingt irgendwelche Stars, sondern es ist eben eine relativ homogene Mannschaft, muss man sagen, die auf den letzten Drückerletzten den Ausstieg aus der Segunda Division geschafft hat und jetzt eine ganz gute Serie gespielt hat. Sie haben zu Beginn gegen Villarreal, gegen Sevilla gespielt, haben gegen Barca ganz gut gespielt, haben ja vorhin schon besprochen. Zum fünften Spiel, da waren wir ja sogar Tabellenführer für eine kurze Zeit. Also bei Granada muss man sagen, dass sie vielleicht mit dem guten Start jetzt diese Euphorie nutzen könnten und dann im Endeffekt gut in der Liga zu bleiben frühzeitig.
Genau, am letzten Spieltag dann in Madrid bei Real 4 zu 2 verloren, davor hat man eben die Liga angeführt. Wenn ich mir angucke, Till die Expected Points, die Granada geholt hat, also eben die statistische Wahrscheinlichkeit aus den abgegebenen Torschüssen, dann Tore zu erzielen und dementsprechend die Siege zu gestalten, dann gibt es da tatsächlich ein relativ großes Delta. Also da liegt Granada eigentlich im Tabellenmittelfeld und hätte mal eben nur 11 Punkte aufgerundet. Das sind zwar immer noch einige für einen Aufsteiger, aber zeigt so ein bisschen, da hat auch wirklich alles funktioniert, was funktionieren musste jetzt in den ersten Spielen oder in den meisten der Spielen.
Ja, ich würde sagen, das ist eigentlich auch eine ganz gute Prognose für die ganze Saison, so diese Range an Punkten, die man da holt. Also ich denke nicht, dass Granada irgendwas mit dem Abstieg zu tun bekommt, dafür sind die zu gut, aber die werden natürlich jetzt auch nicht um die Champions League mitspielen können, was aber nicht ausgeschlossen ist und in der Liga immer möglich, dass halt so Vereine wie Sevilla, Valencia schwächeln und die dann halt irgendwie, so wie die Tafel der Saison ja auch, mit ähnlich einfachem Fußball und relativ defensiv in die Europa League gekommen ist. Also Granada ist schon ein bisschen was zuzutrauen, ich würde die nicht unterschätzen, trotz dieser Statistik. Ja, was man auf jeden Fall bei denen auch hervorheben muss, das täuscht das Torverhältnis ein bisschen. Die haben ja schon zehn Tore kassiert in acht Spielen, aber halt vier gegen Villareal im ersten Spiel und vier gegen Real Madrid im letzten Spiel jetzt. Und sonst nur zwei aus den restlichen sechs, also die sind schon sehr kompakt, unter anderem gegen Barca zu Null gespielt. Also das könnte auf lange Sicht schon oder über die Saison schon für viele Gegner noch relativ eklig werden, gegen die anzutreten. Wozu auch so eine kleine Anekdote von denen passt, denn es wurde erzählt oder es wurde berichtet, dass Trainer Diego Martínez vor dem Spiel gegen Barcelona eine Tafel in die Kabine geschoben hat, auf der jetzt nicht irgendwie ausgeklügelt noch mal die Zuordnung stand oder so, sondern er hat 15 Worte draufgeschrieben, zum Beispiel torhungrig, chameleonartig, entschlossen, intelligent, kompakt, mentale Stärke, also eigentlich Phrasen gedroschen, um so sein Team einzuschwören.
Eine Tech-Cloud.
Stark. Ja, als sei er so ein kleiner Motivationskünstler und das ist für solche Mannschaften, die einfach Fußball spielen und sich wehren müssen, nicht das Schlechteste.
Okay und wer sind die Spieler, außer denen, die du schon genannt hast, Sascha, auf die man da gucken kann? Gibt es da vielleicht auch ein paar Jüngere, die sich vielleicht dann Granada als Sprungbrett heranziehen zu anderen Vereinen? Wenn ich mir zum Beispiel Herrera angucke im defensiven Mittelfeld.
Genau, Herrera ist das auf jeden Fall. Herrera hat man von Menziti ausgeliehen, ist ein ziemlich guter Taktgeber, sorgt eigentlich fast immer für einen Spielaufbau bei Granada im Mittelfeld. Ansonsten hat man noch Davin Mahis, der bei der Copa Amerika schon ziemlich gut aufgespielt hat. Er hat für Venezuela die einzigen zwei Tore erzielt bei der Copa. Er ist auch so ein Oldschool-Flückelspieler, dribbelt ganz gerne, zieht auch gerne mal aus der zweiten Reihe ab. Er ist auch schon 26, also ist er auch nicht so die allerjüngste Truppe. Es ist halt, wie gesagt, eine ganz gute Mischung. In der Innenverteidigung hat man Domingos Duarte geholt, der auch eine ganz gute Rolle spielt und sich eigentlich auch zu einem überdurchschnittlichen La Liga in Verteidigung integrieren kann bei Granada.
Und der ewige Adrian Ramos steht noch im Kader, also er spielt nicht häufig. 74 Minuten, aber da haben wir noch eine weitere Südamerika-Kombo. Übrigens in der Tabelle nach Expected Points auf Platz 1 nicht Atletico, nicht Real, nicht Barca, sondern VIA Real, die müssten nach Expected Points schon ganze fünf Punkte mehr haben als die elf, die sie aktuell gesammelt haben. Muss man mit Vorsicht genießen und so weiter, das ist nur eine statistische Spielerei. Aber ich wollte es an der Stelle mal erwähnen, denn ich glaube, über VIA Real werden wir bestimmt in einem der nächsten La Liga-Kurzpässe auch mal näher sprechen. Heute aber wollen wir uns jetzt dann Sevilla widmen. Die stehen auf dem fünften Tabellenplatz gefühlt. Stehen die da ja immer, es ist der Europa League, also der sichere Europa League-Platz. Ist denn auch alles wie immer bei Sevilla, Till?
Ja, das kann man genau so sagen. Sevilla hat jetzt wieder Monschi zurückgekehrt, der Sportdirektor, also der früher auch für die Erfolge maßgeblich verantwortlich war und für seine Transferpolitik bekannt ist. Da gehen jedes Jahr viele Spieler, kommen jedes Jahr viele Spieler und genauso was auch dieses Jahr. 13 Neuzugänge, 14 Abgänge. Und auch die Spieler waren eigentlich, wie es immer so ist, also ein paar kamen aus Frankreich, ein paar Talente, zum Beispiel Kuhn D für die Innenverteidigung und Ronny Lopez offensiv. Dann kam ein gestandener Stürmer, das war Luc de Jong und Chicharito, auch typische Transfers, eigentlich der Bruder aus Österreich.
Das ist übrigens die kleine Abse, wissen viele gar nicht, die Fußballspieler.
Danke, danke für die Info.
Und Juan Giordano im Mittelfeld, Fernando, das sind alles so typische Sevilla-Transfers, also dieses mittlere Jahr, mit Spielern, die nicht in Top-Teams zu schaffen, aber eine ganz gute Rolle spielen können bei einem anderen. Aber das schlägt sich leider auch spielerisch ein bisschen nieder, denn unter dem neuen Trainer Julen Lopetegui, der ja vorher bei Real und beim spanischen Verband und bei Porto angestellt war, hat sich das noch nicht so ganz gefunden. Also man ist Fünfter mit einer Torlupe, die nennt sich Minus 1, und hat erst 10 Tore geschossen, während man 11 kassiert hat, logischerweise. Also es funktioniert viel noch nicht im Sturm. Die beiden Neuzugange, De Jong und Jujarito, haben De Jong noch gar nicht. Jujarito hat erst in der Euro League getroffen. Bislang verteilen sich die Tore dann. Vier Spieler haben zweimal getroffen, zweimal einer. Also es fehlt noch so ein bisschen an einem, der so ein bisschen heraus schlicht und an dem Spieler, auf dem man zuspielen kann. Wo sich halt auch die Abhänge niederschlagen, was halt auch immer ein Sevillas-Problem ist, jedes Mal halt Benjela nach Monaco und Saravia zu Peje, die im letzten Jahr eigentlich die Alleinunterhalter in Sevillas Offensive waren, was Tore und Vorlagen angehen.
Wie war denn jetzt dann, Sascha, dieses 0 zu 4 in Barcelona? Da kommen ja vier dieser elf Gegentreffer her und Lopetegui kehrt da, na nicht zurück an alte Wirkungsstätte, das ist falsch, aber er kann quasi mal im großen Lampenlicht rampendlich zeigen, meine Güte. Es ist schwer, im Lampenlicht zeigt er einfach mal, wie weit er jetzt bei Sevilla gekommen ist. Und das ist ein Spiel, aus dem werde ich nur von da drauf schauen, nicht schlauend. Ich konnte es eben leider nicht sehen. Ich habe einmal zwei Platzverweise gegen Barca-Spieler, allerdings schon beim Stand von 4 zu 0 in der 87. und 88. Minute. Ich habe aber schon auch relativ viele Abschlüsse von Sevilla, nämlich 16 in diesem Spiel und Barca selber hatte nur 15, wenn auch mehr davon aufs Tor ging. Und Lopetegui habe ich noch in Erinnerung als jemanden, der gerne in so einem 4-3-3 spielt und dann eben ein positiongetreues Ballbesitzspiel aufzieht mit eben vielen kurzen Pässen. Und dann trägt man den Ball so gemächlich nach vorne, bis der Gegner irgendwann mal eine Lücke aufmacht und man da durchspielen kann. Ist denn das auch dann jetzt das, was wir bei Sevilla sehen?
Würde ich so unterschreiben. Ja, also gegen Barca war das Ergebnis definitiv zu hoch. Also alleine lügt Jong, dem wir vorhin schon angesprochen hatten, dass er immer noch kein Tor erzielt hätte, gegen Barca alleine schon in den ersten 25 Minuten dreimal treffen können. Also das war wirklich unfassbar. Bei der letzten Chance stand er auf der Linie und drückte ihn noch zwei Meter vor der Linie über die Latte. Das war auch ganz kurios.
Da hast du die Aura von Tess Stegen gehalten.
Ja, aber auch von Oppenäuer ist auch gut, muss ich sagen. Deswegen täuchte dieses hohe Ergebnis über die Leistung von Sevilla Rüber, die eigentlich gut war, muss ich sagen. Aber man hat eben das Tor dann nicht gemacht. Und dann hat Barca, also getreu diesem alten Spruch, wenn du deine Chancen vorne nicht machst, dann und so weiter. Dann hat Barca eben einen kurzen Prozess gemacht. Suarez trifft einmal per Fallrückzieher, Messi trifft einmal per Freistuss, der jetzt auch nicht unhaltbar war, muss ich sagen. Da hat Sevilla dieses Jahr auch – oder hat Flavčić, der Torhüter von Sevilla, dieses Jahr auch keine so gute Saison bisher. Und dadurch ist das Ergebnis ein bisschen zu hoch ausgefallen. Und die roten Karten, die Barca da bekommen hat in dem Spiel, möchte ich noch mal ganz kurz auf Mathieu Large eingehen. Ja, es ist ein schwieriger Schiedsrichter, der sich gerne selbst auf die große Bühne stellt und versucht, da selber irgendwie seine Show abzuziehen. Er hat dann Dempélé für eine angebliche Beleidigung da rot gegeben, aber eines der Werte sprach nach dem Spiel davon, dass das gar nicht sein kann, weil er hat Dempélé noch niemals auf Spanisch irgendetwas reden hören.
Gut, vielleicht ein multilingualer Schiedsrichter. Wir erinnern uns alle an die rote Karte gegen Diego bei Werder Bremen im Europa League Halbfinale, damals als er Madre di Puta oder irgendjemanden so gesagt hat, und das auch zu einem nicht-spanisch sprechenden Schiedsrichter. Also, wer weiß. Können wir denn davon ausgehen, dass dann Sevilla wieder die Europa League gewinnt, so wie immer? Also in Karabak 3-0 gewonnen, jetzt gegen Nikosia, trainiert natürlich vom ewigem Thomas Doll 1-0, das sicher nach Hause gefahren mit Du Lange. Jetzt noch einen Exoten, der auch schon mal überrascht hat in der letzten Saison, aber bisher in der Saison jetzt noch nicht so wahnsinnig brillieren konnte. Das sieht für mich ehrlich gesagt so aus, wie immer. Sevilla wird fünfter in der Liga, ganz ganz eventuell werden sie vierter, aber in den letzten sechs Jahren haben sie das genau einmal geschafft, ansonsten waren sie immer fünfter, sechster oder siebter. Und man kommt aber in der Europa League wahnsinnig weit.
Ja, also man muss halt auch zur Ligasituation so ein bisschen sagen, dass die ersten drei Plätze in Spanien mittlerweile geblockt sind von Atletico Real und Barca. Und deswegen ist dieser vierte Platz auch sehr umkämpft zwischen Valencia und Sevilla in erster Linie. Aber dann gibt es natürlich immer noch mal so Überraschungs-Mannschaften, die da reinhalten. So Reals Cascade hat es zum Beispiel mal geschafft, Bell Baur hat es auch mal geschafft. Und ich denke, dass der Weg in die Top-League für Sevilla, wenn dann fast schon sicherer über die Euro League geht, aber das kann man natürlich zu wenig sagen in einem K.o.-Wettbewerb. Und die letzten europäischen Erfolge sind jetzt auch schon wieder vier, fünf Jahre her. Also, die Vorrunde wird man locker überstehen und man wird wahrscheinlich auch relativ weit kommen. Traditionell sind ja spanische Mannschaften, auch die kleineren spanischen Mannschaften, der Euro League stark. Aber, ob man die jetzt gewinnen wird, wer weiß. Was ich aber glaube, ist, dass man sich in der Liga noch stabilisiert. Also, weil dieses Spiel gegen Barcelona war natürlich 0 zu 4, hohes Ergebnis. Aber da hat halt, wie man an den Chancen, die sich Sevilla rausgespielt hat, dieses 4-3 von Le Petit Gugui ganz gut funktioniert. Vorher hatten die halt häufiger Probleme. Wenn dazu dritt, Juan Jordan, der relativ defensiv ist, Fernando, der eigentlich streng defensiv ist, und Van Nega, der so ein bisschen diesen Kreativgeist haben sollte, im Dreieinmittelfeld gespielt haben, hat man sich halt häufig zum Innenverteidiger, zum Linksverteidiger, Rechtsverteidiger die Bälle so hin und her geschoben und irgendwie nicht den Weg in die Spitze gefunden. Und das hat dann gegen Barcelona schon besser funktioniert. Also macht die hohe Niederlage vielleicht sogar ein bisschen Hoffnung, dass es in den nächsten Wochen noch erfolgreicher läuft. Als es bis jetzt ja schon relativ erfolgreich lief.
Interessante Argumentation, aber man kann ihr überraschend gut folgen nach allem, was ihr jetzt zu Sevilla erzählt habt. Jetzt wollen wir sprechen über Valencia und da war mal wieder was los. Ach, Valencia, es ist einfach das gute alte Valencia, wie man es seit ein paar Jahren kennt. Sascha, bringen wir uns mal auf den Stand, was ist denn da passiert?
Da kann es hier, glaube ich, eher was zu sagen zu den ganzen Vorkommnissen. Ansonsten vielleicht mal das Sportliche, um das mal kurz abzuklappern. Also man hat halt diesem Jahr oder im Sommer hätte man eigentlich zumindest den offensiven Mannschaftsteil noch nachlegen müssen. Man hätte noch einen kreativen Mittelfeldspieler für das Zentrum holen müssen. Das hat man auch nicht getan. Da hat er darauf vertraut, dass Dani Barrejo, der mittlerweile 30 Jahre alt ist, über noch gefühlt alle drei Tage spielen kann und hat dann im Sturm Rodrigo überraschenderweise halten können, da er angeblich auch zu kurz vor einem Wechsel zu Atletico stand. Den hat man halten können. Hat dann auch Maxi Gomez von Saltevico geholt, der sich schon recht gut eingefahren hat mit vier Toren, aber immer noch so ein bisschen eine Erfindungsphase braucht, weil er sich schon stark auf einen Rodrigo anpassen muss, auf den das ganze Spiel in der Offensive klar zugeschlitten ist. Dann hat man noch mit Gamero einen dritten Stürmer, der eigentlich auch ein potenzieller Stammspieler ist. Da wird man eben auch schauen, wie man ihn dann einbinden kann. Das große Problem ist, oder das Problem, was man sich selber geschaffen hat, ist eben, dass man Trainer Marcelino beurlaubt hat. Und dadurch irgendwie dieser ganze Plan, der aufgegangen ist, also dieser Fitnessplan, den man als Mannschaft hatte, er ging nicht auf. Das hat sich dadurch geäußert, dass Perejo und auch Rodrigo komplett überspielt waren, völlig müde waren in den Ligaspielen teilweise, weil sie eben in kurzer Zeit drei Spiele hatten. Das liegt eben auch daran, dass sie aktuell auch nicht so das abrufen, was der Kader eigentlich drin hätte.
Aber warum hat man denn sich dann von Marcelino getrennt? Der ist seit 2017 Trainer gewesen, hat 110 Spiele immerhin gecoacht für Valencia. Also der war da ganz gut im Sattel. Und wenn ich mir jetzt so den Saisonstart von Valencia angucke, dann sieht das jetzt nicht ganz berühmt aus. Es wirkt jetzt aber auch nicht so, als wäre da irgendwas so komplett aus den Fugen geraten.
Ja, also das hat keine sportlichen Gründe gehabt, die Entlassung, muss man leider so hart sagen. Die hat stattgefunden nach drei Saisonspielen mit vier Punkten. Also kein guter Start, aber auch kein schlechter Start. Und entzündete sich an einem Streit zwischen Marcelino und dem Sportdirektor Matteo Alemanni auf der einen Seite und Besitzer Peter Lim, dem Indonesier, auf der anderen Seite, der sich in Valencia von einem Vertreter hat nur vertreten lassen und seine Geschäfte eigentlich aus Indonesien herausführt. Und der ist ja eng verwandelt mit dem einmächtigen Spielerberater Jorge Mendez. Und genau daran hat sich Valencia eigentlich schon in den vergangenen Jahren häufiger Probleme geschaffen mit den verkorksten Verpflichtungen von Gary Neville und Nuno Espíritu Santo zum Beispiel. Und mit Marcelino schien es so, als sei alles wieder am rein und so war es auch. Man hat sich zweimal für die Champions League qualifiziert, man hat den Pokal gewonnen im letzten Jahr. Die Fans haben den Trainer quasi geliebt und im Sommer hat sich dann der Streit so ein bisschen daran entzündet, dass Rodrigo eben zur Atletico verkauft werden sollte, wo Marcelino sich schon in die Medien hingestellt hat und gesagt, ja dazu kann ich nichts sagen, ich weiß nicht alles, was hier im Verein passiert. Und gleichzeitig hat der dann auch gesagt, wenn Rodrigo geht, dann können wir die Ziele nicht erreichen, weil Sevilla und Betis investiert haben, was hat Marcelino gar nicht gepasst und dann schließt, hat Peter Lim, sorry, Peter Lim gar nicht gepasst und dann schließt auch Marcelino's Bitte nach neun Spielern namentlich Rafinha und Denis Suárez und Barcelona auf taube Ohren, die ja eigentlich als Verstärkung genau diese offensiven Kreativspieler, die Sascha eben angesprochen hat, die da noch Ferien ausgemacht hat. Die sind dann stattdessen zu Celta Vigo gegangen, Lim hat das lakonisch kommentiert mit, sie hätten der eigenen Jugend den Weg verbaut. Soweit so gut und dann kommt man eigentlich zum absoluten Streitpunkt, wo dann Rojo Mendes auch ins Spiel kommt. Marcelino hat sich nämlich geweigert, so sagt man, Spieler zu verpflichten, die von Mendes betreut wurden, weil halt viele schlechte Erfahrungen damit gemacht wurden, häufig Spiele dann einfach geparkt wurden und Mendes sich einfach zu sehr in die Geschäfte eingemischt hat. Das wollte Marcelino nicht und dadurch, dass das auch nicht mehr passiert ist, hat Valencia nicht die letzten zwei Jahre so erfolgreich gespielt. Und der Streit hat sich dann über die ersten Wochen so entzündet, dass man schließlich Marcelino entlassen hat. Und das hat auf allen Ebenen in der Mannschaft, bei den Fans und auch bei Vereinslegenden wie Kandi, zum Beispiel Sandago Candisarri, Riesenaufregung gesorgt. Also ich kann da zwei Zitate. Einmal hat Ezekiel Garay gesagt, also sein Zeichen gestandener Innenverteidiger gesetzt, absoluter Führungsspieler in der Mannschaft. Er hat gesagt, wie auch immer diese Entscheidung gefällt hat, der hat nicht nur dich, also Marcelino, übergangen. Er hat auch eine ganze Mannschaft und die Fans mit runtergezogen. Etwas, was ich laut und klar sagen will, es ist nicht fair. Also man hat sich halt eigentlich ein Riesenproblem im Haus gemacht, worunter dann auch der Nachfolger zu leiten hat. Also der Nachfolger ist Albert Celades, der war Co-Trainer bei der U21 von der spanischen Mannschaft und wird von Jorge Mendes wiederum betreut. Also der nächste. Dem man sich quasi ins Haus geholt hat. Dazu hat dann Canisares, da komme ich dann zu meinem zweiten relativ krassen Zitat, also der war ja lange Irrigator von Valencia, stand im Champions-League-Finale zweimal. Er hat gesagt, Celades hat seinen Anstand und seinen Moralverkauf für einen Job in der ersten Liga. Das hängt so ein bisschen, wie der gesehen wird von außen. Und was halt auch zu erwarten ist, denn ein schwacher Trainer wird nicht widersprechen, was Macedino halt getan hat und was halt auch für den Erfolg ein bisschen gesorgt hat. Und dadurch einfach einen schweren Stand gegenüber Peter Lim, gegenüber Mendes, gegenüber all den Einflüssen, die er von außen herrschen haben. Und umgekehrt auch einen schweren Stand bei der Mannschaft, die mit Macedino weiterarbeiten wollte und bei den Fans. Also Valencia sieht im sehr turbulenten Jahr entgegen und es ist zu befürchten, es steht zu befürchten, dass man trotz des guten Kaders das, was man sich in den letzten zwei Jahren wieder aufgebaut hat, nachdem man ja auch schon mal gegen den Abschied gespielt hat, mit dem Hintern wieder eingesessen hat. Und ja, also für Los Chays traurige Tage.
Das ist schon verrückt. Also ich fasse noch mal kurz zusammen. Der Investor und Besitzer von Valencia hat einen Machtkampf zwischen Trainer und einem Spielerberater, der viele Spieler untergebracht hat, zugunsten des Beraters entschieden, so wie wir es alle getan hätten. Daraufhin hat man einen Trainer engagiert oder hochgezogen aus der eigenen Jugend, der wiederum genau von diesem Berater beraten wird. Das ist toll. Das ist Fußball im Jahr 2019. Meine Güte. Und dann 0 zu 3 zu Hause gegen Ajax verloren, nach dem etwas schmeichelhaften 1 zu 0 in London bei Chelsea in der Champions League. Das wird jetzt auch nicht unbedingt dafür sorgen, dass es ruhiger wird, vermute ich mal.
Genau. Vor allem, weil dieses 1 zu 0 gegen Chelsea direkt nach der Entlassung war. Also böse Zungen würden jetzt behaupten, da war dann quasi noch Marcelino's Einfluss. Wir verantwortlich. Und ein paar Wochen später lässt man sich dann zu Hause 0 zu 3 abschießen gegen Ajax.
Gut. Also Valencia, behalten wir im Blick jetzt mit all dem Hintergrundwissen, was wir dazu bekommen haben. Ihr habt außerdem noch mir geschrieben, dass ihr gerne über Ossasuna reden wollen würdet. Sascha, wenn ich mir die angucke, dann sehe ich da zwei Siege, fünf Unentschieden, eine Niederlage und ein Torverhältnis von 7 zu 7 Toren. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, warum Ossasuna trotzdem einen näheren Blick wert ist.
Weil Ossasuna seit dem 1. April 2018 ungeschlagen ist zu Hause.
Das sind wie viele Spiele?
Das sind 29 Spiele. Das hat unter anderem Barca einen Punkt abgetrotzt, im Estadio El Sala, was relativ klein ist. Es passen nur knapp 20.000 Zuschauer rein. Das erinnert auch ein bisschen von außen an La Bombonera, das Time-Stadium von Boca. Es ist recht klein, gedrungen, so eine englische Atmosphäre. Die ganzen Fans, die ganzen Bewohner und Pamplona sind dafür bekannt, dass sie ihre Vereine aus der Umgebung unterstützen. Wenn man nicht Barca oder Real unterstützen, sondern eben diesen Lokalpatriotismus betreiben, was Fußball angeht. Da gibt es natürlich dieses ganze Stadium, dieses ganze Umfeld, das den Spielern noch einmal mehr auftrieben und zorgt für eine Hexenkessel-Stimmung. Was natürlich als Aufsteiger extrem wichtig ist, das Stadium soll jetzt umgebaut werden. Da durften die Fans interessanterweise auch mit abstimmen, welchen Wurf ihnen gefällt. Da hat man sich dafür entschieden, das Projekt Mururoho, also quasi die rote Mauer, umzusetzen. Da werden jetzt quasi etwa 6000 Plätze oben drauf gesetzt als Oberrang noch mal. Und noch mal zu 1.300 Stehplätze werden auch noch hinzugefügt. Also würde das nochmal eine größere Hexenkessel werden dort bei Osasuna. Die dort ganz klar – also, das ist halt ein Aufsteiger, sie spielen in ihrem 4-4-2 relativ vielen Kontern, das ist halt ein klassischer Aufsteiger. Man muss natürlich auch dazu sagen, dass sie eben erst zwei Siege haben, viele Unentschieden dabei haben. Aber wenn man als Aufsteiger wirklich so eine High-Macht ist, in der eigenen Stadt dann immer seine Punkte zuverlässig holt, dann sind die absolut voll im Soll. Und ich denke auch nicht, dass Osasuna jetzt nicht irgendwas Großes passieren soll, dass denen da irgendwelche Abschiedsängste bevorstehen.
Ja gut, das ist natürlich schon einiges für einen Aufsteiger. Und eben dieses Stadion, weil du jetzt auch gerade ein paar Besucherzahlen genannt hast, beziehungsweise eben ein paar Zahlen für den Ausbau. Insgesamt hat man eben in der Saison jetzt einen Schnitt von 15.000. Also eben ein sehr kleines Bonbonera. Also das Bonbonera ist ja dann doch größer, da passen ja ein paar mehr rein. Also eben sehr, sehr klein, aber eben eine Heimfestung.
Und das wird dann noch verstärkt, damit diesen Neubau, der dann ziemlich cool aussieht, mit diesem Oberrang, der kompletten Rot gehalten wird und dann eben mit den Farben von Ostas Juno dort beleuchtet werden soll.
Interessant und könnt ihr mir erklären, warum zumindest laut transfermarkt.de in den ganzen letzten Jahren, also das letzte Mal ein ausverkauftes Spiel gab es in der Saison 2007, 2008? Das passt da jetzt irgendwie überhaupt nicht mit dazu. Ist das ein Fehler in der Statistik, die ich hier vor mir habe oder gibt es da noch irgendeine Geschichte dahinter?
Ist mir jetzt nichts weiter bekannt, ich weiß halt nur, dass bei OstaSuna damals – wo ich gegen Villareales glaube ich mal – Teile vom Stadion eingestürzt oder vom Zaun eingestürzt sind. Ich glaube 2011 oder so. Da gab es Schlagzeilen. Aber warum die jetzt nie ausverkauft sind, das wundert mich auch ein bisschen, ehrlich zu sein. Es wirkt immer ziemlich laut da drin.
Ja, es ergibt eben keinen Sinn, deswegen habe ich die Frage gestellt. Aber wer weiß, welche Geschichte dahinter steht. Lohnt es sich dann auch, Spiele von Osasuna anzugucken oder ist das jetzt eher so – also jetzt nichts für Feinschmecker, sondern eher für Liebhaber der Fußballkultur, die sich dann dran erfreuen können, dass so ein Aufsteiger mit so einem besonderen Stadion sich etablieren kann in der ersten Liga?
Da muss ich den Hörern keine falschen Hoffnungen machen, dass da jetzt irgendwas spektakulär ist. Das ist halt ein Aufsteiger, der auf Konzert spielt, das Defensive hat und keine wirklichen Stars im Team hat. So in dem Sinne.
Okay.
Wobei man einen Ein-Spieler nennen kann, was ich finde, nämlich Jimmy Avila, das ist ein Argentinier, der ist im Sommer von San Lorenzo gekommen, 2, 7 Millionen Ablöse, also ein Schnäppchen für heutige Verhältnisse. Hat seinen Marktwert jetzt schon auf 5 Millionen gesteigert, hat bis jetzt zwei Tore gemacht und zwei gelegt. Für mich in den Spielen, die ich gesehen habe, war der Dreh- und Angelpunkt der beste bei Mersasuna. Der ist 25 Jahre alt und ich traue ihm zu, wenn er jetzt eine gute Saison spielt, dass man ihm in der nächsten Saison zu so einem typischen Sevilla-Transfer wird, zum Beispiel.
Stimmt, vom Alter her passt er genau zu Sevilla. Das stimmt. Immer wenn man denkt, naja, schon ein bisschen leicht zu alt, um quasi als Talent zu gelten, dann ist es ein Sevilla-Transfer. Stimmt. Ja, gut, auf den gucken wir näher. Jimmy Avila aus Argentinien, jetzt eben bei Ossasuna zu sehen. Was lässt sich denn dann noch zu Retafel sagen? Die liegen hinter Ossasuna auf Platz 12 genau oder relativ in der Mitte der Tabelle mit einer ziemlich ausgeglichenen Bilanz. Zwei Siege, zwei Niederlagen, vier Unentschieden, 12 zu 12 Tore.
In meinen Augen pendelt sich Retafel genau da ein, wo es auch realistisch hingehört. Die werden nicht absteigen, denke ich, aber die Erfolge der letzten Saison kann man auch nicht wiederholen. Da hat man eben auch so wie Granada gespielt, sehr defensiv gestanden, sehr einfach im Fußball gespielt und sich sehr lange oben gehalten und dann fast sogar die Champions League geschafft. Jetzt sieht man einfach, dass die Mannschaft ein bisschen überperformt hat und sich jetzt im Mittelfeld einfindet.
Das war so ein bisschen die schöne Geschichte der letzten Saison bei Rithafel.
Ich muss dazu noch sagen, dass sie aktuell vorne noch mit ihrem Opa-Sturm, also aus Roja Molina, der 37 ist, Raimund Marta mit 31 und Rodrigues mit 33, nicht den allerjüngsten und spritzigsten Sturm haben. Aber die haben letzte Saison halt zu dritt 75 Prozent der Tore geschossen. Also 36 der 48 Treffer haben die drei alten Männer davon erzielt. Insofern ist das eigentlich auch eine Truppe, die dieses Jahr auch keine Probleme haben wird, denke ich. Nach unten gesehen, aber auch nicht nach oben irgendwelche Ausreise haben wird. Ist halt eine ziemlich robuste Truppe. Die haben aktuell die meisten gelben Karten mit 31. Zum Vergleich Sevilla, die haben 23. Das sind die Mannschaften mit den zweitmeisten gelben Karten. Also gegen die kann es auch schon mal ungemütlich werden spielen.
Nach acht Spielen 31, das ist durchaus eine ganz gute Statistik. Die sind auch in der V-Tabelle, wenig überraschend. Ganz weit nach vorne 19, 4 Vs im Schnitt pro Spiel. Das ist ja fast schon die magische 20-V-Thomas-Tuche-Grenze. Ab dann, wo es quasi unfair wird. Also die langen ordentlich hin und haben vorne dann ein paar erfahrenere Spieler, um es mal so zu nennen, rund um den Kapitän Molina mit 37, die dann eben dann das Gro der Tore schießen, aber können das einfach nicht wiederholen, was wir in der letzten Saison ja auch so ein bisschen begleitet haben, diesen ja fast Ausflug ins internationale Geschäft. Das ist so ein bisschen die Geschichte von Retafel. Dann lasst uns noch sprechen über Alaves. Die liegen aktuell auf Platz 17, haben zwei Siege, zwei Unentschieden, vier Niederlagen, fünf zu neun Tore. Das ließ sich alles nicht so wahnsinnig gut. Und wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, Till, dann hatte Alaves ja eigentlich auch bessere Phasen schon in seiner Vereinshistorie und durchaus ja auch in der jüngeren Vergangenheit. Wenn ich jetzt nicht komplett falsch liege, wie läuft da die Saison an?
Das täuscht ein bisschen bei Alaves, denn die haben eigentlich nur ein großes Erfackniveau.
Warte, Till, wir hören dich leider nicht so wirklich gut. Sascha, kannst du die Antwort geben?
Genau, also Alaves gehört letztes Jahr eigentlich auch zu den Mannschaften, die eigentlich auch relativ lange oben in die Europa League-Plätze mitgespielt haben. Da hatten dann auch so einen kleinen Einbruch. Man hat jetzt im Sommer einen Trainer gehabt. Man hat relativ frühzeitig in der letzten Saison schon gesagt, dass Trainer Fernandes, dass das mit ihm nicht verlängert wird, hat dann den ehemaligen Trainer von Real Sociedad, Caritano, geholt. Man hat jetzt eben auch mitzukämpfen, überhaupt erst mal so die Offensivpower auf den Platz zu bekommen. Oder die Offensivpower, die man eigentlich gar nicht so richtig hat. Also man hat aktuell fünf Tore geschossen, davon hat ein gewisser auch Rossellou geschossen. Lucas Perez hat zweimal getroffen. Dann kommt auch noch hinzu, dass man eben mit Guillermo Maripan, einem Stamm-Infoteidiger ersetzen musste, der letztes Jahr den Laden dahinten zusammengehalten hat. Man hat letztes Jahr auch eine ganz gute Spielanlage, so ein bisschen wie Atletico-mäßig so gespielt. Auch gut auf Konter kam stark übers Pressing, das greift aktuell noch nicht ganz so. Offensiv ist es nicht wirklich gut aktuell. Man gibt halt zwei Torschüsse pro Spiel ab, was halt wirklich nicht viel ist. Wenn dann eben das Pressing nicht wirklich greift, dann kann man sich ja wirklich ausmalen, warum Alaves so weit unten steht. Aber noch mal, die haben letztes Jahr klar über ihre Möglichkeiten gespielt. Wenn sie dieses Jahr wirklich die Klasse halten, dann ist das völlig okay.
Also wir erinnern uns eben, das meinte ich mit der jüngeren Vergangenheit, Alaves in der letzten Saison eben zwischenzeitlich mal auf Tabellenplatz 2, rund um den 9. und 10. Spieltag. Und bis tatsächlich zum 31. Spieltag lag man auch noch auf Europa-Cup-Plätzen und dann ging es dahin. Am Ende landete man dann auf Platz 11, was immer noch ein Erfolg war, aber dann im Saisonverlauf ein bisschen enttäuschend für Alaves. Da war ein bisschen mehr drin. Till, hast du noch was zu ergänzen zu Alaves, was dir auf der Seele liegt?
Nein, da ist eigentlich alles geschehen. Ihrem Gegner in den Abstieg, ganz klar, in der Saison. Und der größte Erfolg in der Geschichte ist eigentlich, dass sie jetzt – oder in der jüngeren Geschichte ist eigentlich überhaupt die Rückkehr in der Liga, denn die haben lange unterklassig gespielt, waren halt einmal schon in der ersten Liga von 98 bis 2003 und haben da einmal den Einzug in zur EFA Cup-Finale geschafft. Aber der Erfolg wird sich so schnell nicht wiederholen. Und dieses Jahr muss man halt echt aufpassen, dass sie nicht absteigen. Und was man vielleicht noch nennen kann, also neben Rossellou, den Sascha schon gesagt hat, spielt auch als Leihgabe von West Brom ein gewisser Oliver Burke da, der ja auch mal sich in Leipzig versuchen durfte in der Bundesliga.
So einige bekannte Namen hat man da. Und mit einem bekannten Namen wollen wir dann auch den Blick auf La Liga fast schon abschließen, nämlich auf eine Mannschaft, die in der letzten Saison noch auf Platz 7 gelandet ist und jetzt nach acht Spieltagen auf dem vorletzten Tabellenplatz liegt, nämlich Espanyol-Barcelona. Was ist denn bei Espanyol los? Ist das mehr als nur Zufall, dass man so unten drin steckt?
Ne, also bis jetzt ist es auf jeden Fall gar kein Zufall. Denn man muss leider ganz klar sagen, dass sie zurechter unten stehen. Die haben sehr schlecht gespielt und sie haben noch nicht gegen Barcelona gespielt, noch nicht gegen Real, noch nicht gegen Atletico und auch nicht gegen Bilbao. Halt Teams, die eigentlich oben mitspielen diese Saison. Halt nicht. Also man hat halt die Punkte auch gegen Konkurrenten liegen lassen. Vor der Saison wurde Trainer Rubi, der letzte Saison für den Erfolg eigentlich verantwortlich war. Der war nur ein Jahr da. Der ist zu B-Teams gewechselt, wo er bis jetzt auch nicht so sehr überzeugen kann. Aber das ist ja espanolegal. Die haben ihn mit David Gallego ersetzt. Der war der zweite Trainer der zweiten Mannschaft vorher, der jetzt schon wieder entlassen wurde nach acht Spielen und einem Sieg. Der neue Trainer ist Pablo Marín. Er war erfolgreich bei Girona, bei Sevilla eher semi-erfolgreich und soll jetzt die Kohlen aus dem Feuer holen. Im Prinzip sind die eigentlich zu stark, um abzusteigen. Da gibt es schlechtere Teams in der Liga. Aber da die jetzt noch so harte Bretter zu bohren haben, bis Weihnachten, die gucken, wie man aus der Liga rauskommt. Also, wenn sie so weiterspiegeln müssen, dann mit so einer sehr dritten Spielzeit für den Club in Barcelona.
Weil man ja auch Sascha gleichzeitig noch in der Europa League vertreten ist. Also, das darf man eben nicht vergessen. Wir sprechen hier über Espanol. Die gewinnen dann mal bei ZSK Moskau 2 zu 0 und verlieren dann direkt danach am Wochenende auf Mallorca ebenso mit 2 zu 0. Und Mallorca ist ja, habe ich vorhin schon angesprochen, nur ein Plätzchen über Espanol. Also, das wäre so ein wichtiger Sieg gewesen, um da mal von unten rauszukommen.
Ja, genau, das gegen Valladolid war ja ähnlich. Das sind die Spiele, die sie eigentlich hätten gewinnen müssen. Also, das war dann wahrscheinlich auch folgerichtig, dass Trainer David Gallego dann auch entlassen wurde nach gerade mal 16 Spielen, 16 Pflichtspielen mit der Europa League und der Qualifikationsrunden. War schon der richtige Schritt. Also, die müssen dieses Jahr echt aufpassen, dass Espanol nicht runtergeht.
Wir werden es im Auge behalten.
Und was man bei Espanol auch noch anfügen kann, die haben halt auch wichtige Spielerfahnen mit Borja Iglesias relativ gut getroffen hat und Mario Amosso, dem gesetzten Infanteilgärtnist zu Atletico Madrid gezogen hat. Also da ist man anscheinend auch – der Kader ist ein bisschen aus dem Gleichgewicht geraten – und hat eine Verletzung gegen diejenigen, die da unterwegs sind, nämlich Calerita bei das Argentina, bei das Mittelstürmer, die diese Saison dann ein bisschen die Lücke füllen sollten, die Iglesias gerissen hat und jetzt einige Spiele schon gefehlt haben. Also von daher hat man halt auch ein bisschen Verletzungspech, das muss man zugutehalten, was die Ergebnisse natürlich sich besser macht gegen die Gegner, gegen die man hätte gewinnen müssen.
Ja, das sieht nicht ganz so gut aus bei Espanyol und weil du kurz weg warst, wiederhole ich noch kurz die Abgänge. Iglesias haben wir jetzt gerade noch gehört, das ist ein Mittelstürmer, der zu Betis gewechselt ist und Herr Mosow hattest du noch genannt in Verteidiger zu Atletico. Wir haben leichte Leitungsprobleme, aber darüber wollen wir einfach hinweg moderieren. Was gibt es denn sonst noch so für Themen in La Liga? Was ist denn noch wichtig zu wissen, Sascha?
Am Wochenende des 25. ist der Klassiker Barca gegen Real. Da ist man aktuell in Gesprächen mit dem spanischen La Liga-Verband, dass das Spiel eventuell verlegt werden soll. Entweder jetzt schon direkt nach Madrid oder im Dezember in Barcelona, aufgrund der Unruhen, die aktuell in der Region vorherrschen.
Also mit den katalanischen Zepparatisten.
Genau, da wird aktuell überlegt, ob das Spiel sogar verlegt werden soll. Das zieht man stark in Betracht. Genauso gut wird auch überlegt, hat La Liga aktuell Pläne, das Spiel Atletico gegen Villarreal in die USA nach Miami zu verlegen. Damit hat man ja schon mal vor ein oder zwei Jahren geliebt, dass La Liga-Spiele in Übersicht stattfinden sollen. Diesmal scheint man sich wohl auch in besseren Gesprächen zu befinden als noch in der Vergangenheit. Also könnte es möglich sein, dass da ein Spiel stattfindet in Miami zwischen Atletico und Villarreal.
Aber war es nicht so, dass es in der Vergangenheit abgesagt wurde? Es gab doch mal die Partie Girona gegen Barca, die auch in Miami ausgetragen werden sollte. Und das hat dann der spanische Verband nach Protesten zurückgenommen. Jetzt probiert man einfach genau das Gleiche mit anderen Teams noch mal.
Genau, quasi. Damals ist man daran gescheitert, dass die Spieler ihr Veto eingelegt haben. Vor allem Spieler von Real haben da auch ihr Veto eingelegt. Mich kommt das Sergio Ramos, der auch einer der Wortführer, was es anging. Jetzt versucht man es halt noch mal, kommt anscheinend damit durch. Die Meldung ist relativ frisch. Man muss eben schauen, was da noch bei rumkommt. Ich finde es schade für den normalen Zuschauer an sich, wenn das Spiel dann irgendwie ausgelagert wird, weil es ja trotzdem ein normales Ligaspiel ist. Natürlich für die US-Amerikaner, die dann auch mal ihre Stars aus der Liga sehen wollen, ist es natürlich eine feine Sache. Aber ich weiß auch nicht, ob das so der Sinn der Sache ist, da irgendwelche Spiele auszulagern, nur um zwei, drei Millionen Euro mehr zu bekommen. Oder wahrscheinlich noch mehr Summen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das so der Weg ist, wie man da gehen sollte.
Ja, vor allem ist es ja auch nicht irgendwie am Rande der Saison oder irgendwie so, dass man das noch abfangen kann. Sondern der Plan ist ja, dass das Spiel am 6. Dezember stattfindet. Und am 11. Dezember, also fünf Tage später, spielt dann Atletico zu Hause gegen Lokomotive Moskau in der Champions League, während man am Wochenende vorher zu Hause gegen Barca spielt. Also das sind jetzt auch durchaus Spiele, wo ich sagen würde, ein Jetlag, den du dir da auf jeden Fall einfängst, spielt da eine wichtige Rolle. Wir beobachten, ob die Spieler wieder revolutieren und ob es dann vielleicht doch noch mal zurückgedreht wird. Aber es scheint ja so zu sein, als ob sowas einfach im modernen Fußball jetzt Teil der Sache ist. Wer weiß, ob La Liga da nicht einfach nur ein Vorreiter ist. Ja, ich würde sagen, damit haben wir doch diese ersten 8 Spieltage und auch das bisschen, was da europäisch schon zu sehen war, der für eine ganz gut besprochen. Ich danke euch beiden sehr, dass ihr euch Zeit genommen habt. Trotz aller Widrigkeiten, die wir hatten. Ein paar davon sind auch in der Aufnahme gelandet, aber hoffentlich nicht zu viele. Entschuldigt das bitte, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Wir haben, also ich glaube, wir können mit Fug und Recht behaupten, nachdem wir es über drei verschiedene Wege versucht haben, miteinander zu sprechen, dass wir jetzt keine andere Möglichkeit, also bis aufs Dosentelefon oder Anruf auf dem Handy hatten wir jetzt keine andere Möglichkeit mehr. Es ging jetzt nur so. Ich danke euch beiden sehr. Zum einen Sascha Felter, et Sascha Fültrer, also ohne die Vokale auf Twitter, wird natürlich verlinkt und Till Oppermann, der praktischerweise auch et Till Oppermann auf Twitter heißt, von Cavani's Friseur. Danke euch beiden, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt für den Rasenfunk. Und ich empfehle an der Stelle nochmal, hört in den Podcast von Cavani's Friseur rein, ganz frisch gestartet und die Jungs freuen sich natürlich auch über Feedback, so wie das ja immer ist, wenn man ein neues Projekt an den Start bekommt. Danke euch für eure Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das war Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 138. Wenn ihr es noch nicht gehört habt, es gibt ein Tribüngespräch mit Holger Badstuber. Knackige 3 Stunden 45 Minuten und hört es schnell weg, denn natürlich wird auch am nächsten Montag die nächste Schlusskonferenz zur Bundesliga erscheinen. Bis dahin habt eine gute Zeit, macht's gut, ciao!